[Música]
ainda cansado aqui ninguém
já no fim da noite né então vamos lá um
boa noite galera eu queria perguntar pra
vocês qual o poder de um simples par de
óculos pra muita gente nessa sala
talvez o oxi é só um objeto de design
uma maneira de enxergar como um simples
objetos do dia a dia pode ser um jeito
de você vê essa vaca que está a cinco
graus de miopia normal essa vaca podia
ser um dinossauro quarta o leão na
áfrica
quero mostrar aqui hoje é que um óculos
pode ser muito mais poderoso que isso no
mundo 680 milhões de pessoas
precisamos a óculos não podem pagar por
eles imagina que quem usa óculos para
você viver sem isso
o impactante seria sua vida eu queria
contar a realidade e mostrar que como
está sendo mudado hoje no malauí
lá é um país aqui no sul da áfrica a
luta
assim a zona da áfrica em baixo além do
malauí
segundo o fmi ainda não relatou 2005 uma
lei é o país mais pobre do mundo
quando eu falei com o pessoal que morava
lá e fazem não é o terceiro em nossa
idéia agora é outro não é o quarto foi
cara boa e meu país vocês são muito
felizes mas é um país que tem muitos
problemas
algumas fotos de lá com a logística é
feita no maláui bicicleta
a família é uma coisa diferente do
malauí fiquei impressionado quando tive
contato com o pessoal de lá
a última notícia não tá dando pra mim
muito bem do último escândalo do malauí
a onu foi mal em fazer vários exames de
saúde das pessoas
lá no sul do malauí é a capital do globo
em longa e entrei no meio tem o sombra
que a nossa comunidade lá no sul do
malauí como e algodão foi pra lá
a gente sabe mas que as pessoas tinha
anemia e falou urbano diz louçã guitarra
baixo ser um erro como tal como era
diferente a realidade
eles entenderam isso como existiam
vampiros e de fato de acreditar que os
blues sanctis estavam dominando o malawi
e todo mundo era diferente na vila e
para matar as pessoas
oito pessoas morreram no ataque de
vampiros 140 foram presos ea ordem que
sair de sombra porque acreditava em
vampiros é uma onda vampiro com theo
estou falando do 20 anos atrás que foi
outubro 2017 daria pra lá embaixo
essa realidade do malauí a gente era de
malauí do saimon saiba tem 80 anos de
idade ele nunca usando óculos na vida
ele sequer sabia que óculos existia
é normal não enxergar no malauí é normal
você tem dois meses de fome
você faz a colheita teve culturas a
colheita da planta próxima colheita
quando acaba
eu tinha 15 os filhos cinco já morreram
e ele falou que muitos de fome
e quando a gente entregou o primeiro
óculos por saimon ele botou o óculos ele
consegue enxergar e viu que podia
enxergar de fato e foi à casa dele
estava senhor saiu porque não foi o
marketing porque está sem óculos
ele falou porque eu uso para poder
acolher eu quero pegar a semente na
lavoura
eu não posso perder esse óculos porque o
único ao seu posto na minha vida pra ele
mas gente pegar somente na lavoura
são dois meses de fome ele perde 10% e
semente que ele não consegue enxergar é
um mês a mais de fome
isso pode significar a vida ou a morte
do saimon com essa é uma uma escola
perto de zumba aos 300 quilômetros foram
feitos diagnósticos em todas as crianças
que ninguém lá nunca nenhuma das
crianças 254 crianças na escola sequer
tinha feito exame de vista usando óculos
um terço precisava as notas melhoraram
quase 30 a 40 por cento desempenho
qualitativo que não têm nota tão bem
feito mas o desempenho do professor
lamentou muito gostoso pra enxergar
seu sorriso uma criança pode chegar
esse é o marketing o mar tem o gênio que
inventou a solução o renato falou com
fio de aço 2 leis policarbonato e um
plástico em que trabalhava e consegue
fazer um óculos de baixo custo
ele é louco do videoclipe malawi pessoas
como chalita pode montar um óculos e
pontar localmente ou a população local é
um trabalho digno para as pessoas mesmo
tempo entregando algo de baixo custo
o foco dessa máquina esse filamento de
aço é dobrado de fato dobrado
no processo ben manual do plástico
plástico
o acordo é porque eles gostam bastante
cor no dou esse gênero elétrica esquenta
no carvão
isso vai virando óculos
lá a realidade é bem diferente não
existe afirmou lojista hoje a doctor
então a gente treinar as pessoas da
comunidade
elas fazem seu próprio exame óbvio não é
um exame oftalmológico
acho que enxergava 00 85 chegar a 90 95
é muito melhor que zero já foram mais de
10 no malauí hoje 15 mil óculos pessoas
possam enxergar e sua função doado está
preso na comunidade elas vão para a vila
fazer o exame em conta as pessoas pagam
muito bem disse a favela pode pagar a
comunidade pode pagar as obras até
acesso ao produto e geram renda para a
comunidade os produtores as pessoas que
vendem e dá acesso à lusa que as pessoas
não conheciam o que é fã de balawi lugar
muito diferente
o vovô a do malauí o brasil já que a
realidade no brasil é de fato diferente
do que a lógica é muito diferente da que
de fato não existe no brasil já conhece
sua susana tem 76 anos 15 filhos
cinquenta e seis netos e vários bisnetos
eu o trouxe do brasil derrotou jogos de
baixo custo em mais 2014
ano passado eu fui pra marcar puro em
uma comunidade que fica
ia de carro de manaus da cidade ele fez
exame de vista em estava doando óculos
não sei como nós usamos que mora cinco
horas e meia de barco quatro horas de
van descobriu que ele estava fazendo
nessa atividade e manacapuru
ela foi até a gente ela e mais quatro
pessoas da família chegaram lá
os cinco tinham alta miopia estava de
óculos de perto ou sai ano e que achava
do comentário estava com a galera da
alemanha o documentário e lógicas
quiseram conhecer caso não poder fazer o
personagem do documentário
a gente foi lá no dia seguinte e foi
embaixo do ano passado ele foi à
comunidade é com essa família toda e
claro a gente não pode levar isso não
pôde ir ao médico na água o planejado
antes do que todo mundo ali dentro o
herói genético tinha alta miopia a gente
vai voltar lá a gente voltou em julho
deste ano quando estava no outro
documentário eu pude voltar um jogador
susana a gente fez em exames entregou 70
óculos avançando que o oxi apesar de
nossos ano
a gente tem o vídeo da nossa zona
costurando pela primeira vez depois de
15 anos e renda para o nosso samba hoje
no brasil 85% dos municípios no total o
lojista a gente leve para amazonas
amazonas tem 62 municípios
só cinco têm oftalmo sendo que quatro
deles tem um eo quinto em manaus
mas se você tirar manaus da conta você
tem um hospital muito pra cada 456 mil
pessoas no interior do estado
a oms para que o mínimo recomendado é um
para 17 mil e lá tenho para 456 pessoas
que não têm acesso de jeito nenhum
médico jeito nenhum acesso a um óculos
de grau
esse é o brasil hoje o maior motivo de
vergonha para o país 22 9 por cento da
brasil escolar está ligado a uma divisão
inglesa em crianças e óculos
ele fala muito de mudar a educação a
resposta melhor escola pública do mundo
todo mundo conhece todo mundo
se a criança ali na ponta e não enxerga
não vai aprender
o brasil tem a terceira maior taxa de
evasão escolar entre os 100 países como
a itália 24,3 por cento
e essa história tá ali há ali morava uma
comunidade que ficava quatro horas de
barco
manaus uma senhora quando tiveram as
comunidades de atendimento muitas vezes
vai e um médico voluntário nosso médico
ea gente treina comunidade para a
comunidade fazer o atendimento e ajudar
a gente poder reduzir custos e atender
mais gente
ela foi super eficiente brincou fez
cadastro feito triagem e passou eu falei
portuguesa é muito boa a meu sonho é
fazer medicina
a itália tem está muito mais difícil
hoje está mais próximo a 4 horas e meia
de barco
a itália estuda ela possui o melhor
aluno da sala e passou nem passou pelo
exame
a pessoa que é boa aluna é
subdesenvolvido extrovertido precisa de
óculos
eu estava brincando com o aparelho auto
refrator que dá o grau aproximado que
fez exame de vista que lhe pareceu bota
carinha lá recebi um balãozinho e bloom
aparecendo aqui quando videogame né
o plano olho cinco e meio opa
outros 56 e doutora ferrô aparelho é que
50 mil ainda funcionando lá está sozinha
e meio montando consoles nobel de paz e
assim que o meio dele quando você estuda
lá é fácil tudo não é só fala eu copio
quando o recreio em vez do recreio eu
até o quadro e pega o resto
olha a força de vontade que a itália
tinha porque ela chegava de um sonho
muito claro quantos milhares de crianças
não têm essa força de vontade
hoje 42 milhões de brasileiros precisam
de óculos não sabem que precisam
eu aposto com você esse tipo de exame de
vista em todo mundo na sala
muita gente aqui que precisa e não sabe
que precisa é oposta qual é aquele livro
qualquer coisa com vocês neste 40 2
milhões 27 meio de idade economicamente
ativa ea perda de renda da pessoa dessa
idade que os jogos não usa é de 750
dólares 9 centavos por ano - produtiva a
ter mais dificuldade em arranjar emprego
e trabalho no estado
o custo no brasil as pessoas não
enxergam foi exorbitante 21 de dólar por
ano
o simples fato de as pessoas não
enxergar o pagamento o número bem
absurdo mas é que quando a coisa de
poder construir enquanto a gente podia
mudar ele pudesse ter 21 de dólar mais
troféus roubados né
[Música]
esse é o caso do seu pedro
eu tô fazendo amazonas é contestada a
itália conta a história das zonas urbana
e rural do amazonas
seu pedro morava em florianópolis
historicamente as cidades mais ricas do
brasil na capital
ele fez o exame não foi lá parou em um
ônibus hoje tem dois consultórios dentro
aí chegou à comunidade resume todo mundo
ea sequência fazendo é aberto para a
comunidade além de 400 senhas diárias
saem às 8 da manhã às 8 e 20 não tem
mais senha do perfil da semeia ele falou
olha eu perdi o ônibus que eu cheguei o
ônibus pra amiga fala que quer ouvir na
próxima de mim isso não abre a sessão
toda uma história triste só para um
a comunidade inteira em cima da gente
ele falou eu vou sentar aqui que eu
preciso muito
das dez e meia às seis e meia da tarde
concentrados em levantar o sol eu falei
pra vai passa quatro e meio pra perto
ele era marceneiro e perdido um dedo
cortado não enchergava olha renda da
pessoa pede por causa disso e por isso
trouxe essa tecnologia que o marketing
do brasil como renovado em três anos
ante 27 mil óculos em 19 estados
brasileiros
ele fez na verdade mais de 14 mil
consultas um ponto importante vila
giunta pintado ainda desse mapa entanto
não vê que aqui em minas ainda
então fica a dica galera que quer ajudar
fazer algo diferente uma meta muito
usada há um ano passado falou eu quero
impactar um milhão de pessoas até 2020
eo agendamento pelo aniversário de cinco
anos falou aonde quer chegar a 1 bilhão
de pessoas
naquela época a gente impactado 6 mil
pessoas por ano 12 mil óculos ou seja se
tivesse um ano de planejamento de
mudança e você vai ter uma média de 50
mil pessoas em quatro anos
era complicado conta de padeiro levantar
150 milhões de reais e cinco anos para
entregar do álbum
de óculos a gente levantar um milhão e
meio e é bastante bem
as 150 milhões para entender esse
mercado no brasil só conhecer um bonde
que faz isso
já os câncer de barretos isso que todo
cantor sertanejo na prática do cachê por
mês pra ele fazer parte do clube
sertanejo e não replicável até o fim da
conta dos cachês de funk mas não ia
rolar
e aí eu fui estados unidos é muito mais
eficiente que aqui lá desde 200 mil 70
só 144 ondas atingiram 50 milhões de
dólares em faturamento em doação é usado
46 mil empresas já que fazer algo no
meio e não criava empresas e
profissional eu queria impactar suzana
alguém para a itália o seu pedro então
escrever bem é um negócio social
ela bate continua e não fazendo emissões
de títulos lugares mais distantes de
fato precisa e aí de fato consegue mudar
a vida das pessoas
perdendo o foco de acesso muito mais
barato que o mercado tradicional
a gente fala que viu isso pela nossa
história por exemplo
joel que na rocinha na prática na
prática é um segredo alfacinha silva
sena pode pagar 400 r$500 mil reais que
mostra nacional cobre a pagar 50
ela paga sem ela faz ocorre se vira
gente percebeu isso é que foi para a
comunidade conseguiu fazer acontecer
então a gente tem três modelos de
negócios são bem integrado nessa
história para outro toque que a loja
física venda direta entre a multidão ou
de fato a gente consegue integrar o
modelo e chegar onde precisa e dá acesso
a uma vida de qualidade e de baixo custo
e ainda mais legal a gente fala que a
gente não pode esquecer nossa essência
tem lugares que mesmo mesmo com o acesso
não tem condição de pagar o enterro da
amazônia não têm médicos elevado da sua
solução isso é caro então cada ok gente
vem aqui a gente continua financiando um
auto de renovação ou não do acesso pelo
metrô pia para quem de fato precisa
ganhou vários prêmios um dos jovens mais
promissores da plataforma social de
futuro da folha
e aí a gente queria falar que como ele
fez isso né eu fundei a renová fio há
quatro anos atrás mais ou menos dentro
da faculdade
os amigos enquanto cursava 32 o mesmo
tempo fazer direito na usp economia e
administração da usp era muito louco
a gente fazia essa fazer 30 provas no
mês 3 uma semana sete no dia nosso bem
diferente
mesmo assim com 236 juntos a gente
conseguiu levar visão um patrão enquanto
na faculdade para 12 mil pessoas
a mensagem quero falar é que se pode
falar que um par de óculos pode mudar
mudar fome pelo caso josé educação
trabalho e fé renda mas a prática
soluções como essa pode ter outras
soluções para salvador ama vós e outros
negócios sociais
o convite eu quero fazer pra vocês é
você pode começar a transformação do
mundo agora é preciso esperar a vou
trabalhar vou ficar rico mas vou doar
dinheiro a ler bem é um negócio social
ele tem margem superlegal e lucrativo eu
criei meu salário lá dentro
a equipe ganha bem é bem remunerada
mesmo assim a gente muda a vida de muita
gente
a gente vai mudar a vida de um bilhão de
pessoas então galera
vocês querem trabalhar a gente trabalha
com o propósito de mudar o mundo
embora se joga e vai te dar muito
obrigado